sie berichten ja ja immer mal wieder
über die riesige bedrohung die von
asteroiden ausgeht denn auf den punkt
gebracht sind wir ihnen genau wie das
restliche leben auf der erde einfach nur
schutzlos ausgeliefert in diesem
zusammenhang waren forschungsteams
weltweit vor den asteroiden 20 10 11 12
apophis und auch bei denen die nasa zum
gefährlichsten aller bekannten
asteroiden zählt was man alles zu diesen
riesen brocken wissen sollte wie hoch
die bedrohung wirklich ist und ob die
geplante abwehrraketen der nasa
tatsächlich das potenzial hat das leben
auf der erde zu schützen jetzt in klick
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für diesen themen vorschlag
an die whatsapp community so langsam
dämmert es der ganzen menschheit die
erde ist ständig bedroht von kollisionen
mit erdnahen asteroiden und wird auf
dauer von einem riesigen brocken
getroffen werden garantiert viele
objekte sind klein und verglühen in der
atmosphäre ohne dass wir es bemerken
dass ein himmelskörper in die atmosphäre
eindringt und explodiert oder einschlägt
kommt allerdings öfter vor als wir
denken
so wie es eventuell auch mit apophis
passieren könnte den affen kennen wir
seit dem jahr 2005 einen 300 meter
klumpen der nach dem ägyptischen gott
der finsternis und das chaos benannt ist
im jahr 2029 soll er die erde um nur
knapp 30.000 kilometer verfehlen er
fliegt also unter den geostationären
satelliten durch so nah dass wir ihn
vielleicht sogar mit bloßem auge
erkennen können so spekulieren manche
ein paar jahre später nämlich 2095 volk
20 10 11 12 mit einem durchmesser von
etwa zehn metern 116 so hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er auf der erde
einschlagen wird doch wirklich sorgen
machen müssen wir uns derzeit nicht denn
bei seiner größe ist wirklich kein
großer schaden zu erwarten
in 900 jahren dann steht ein
gigantischer asteroid auf dem plan der
az 29 0 75 19 50 dpa mit einem
durchmesser von einem kilometer
forschungsteams haben die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass auf der erde
einschlägt mit 1 zu 300 berechnet und
das ist gar nicht gut aber schon bald
kommt uns wenn er nach einschätzung der
nase einer der gefährlichsten hast so
ihnen überhaupt am 25 september 2001 135
könnte er der erde tatsächlich
gefährlich nahe kommen und das hätte mit
einem durchmesser von 500 metern und
einem gewicht von 87 millionen tonnen
fatale folgen
bei einem aufprall würde er nach
berechnungen der nasa wohl eine energie
von 88.000 atombomben freisetzen das
entspricht einer kinetische energie von
1200 megatonnen uns bleiben also noch
100 jahre um gegenmaßnahmen für diesen
möglichen asteroideneinschlag zu
erarbeiten und genau daran tüfteln die
behörde namens planetary die fans team
der nasa vor kurzem gegründet mit
hochdruck stichwort hemmer
steht für high pavarotti geschen mission
for emergency response wege einen neun
meter langes und knapp neun tonnen
schweres raumschiff das mit einer delta
4 heavy in den weltraum gebracht werden
soll es könnte nicht nur als
transportmittel für eine atombombe
dienen sondern auch als rammbock
beispielsweise für benni denn ein
kleiner schubser könnte den asteroiden
zu einer kursänderung bringen und selbst
wenn dieser erst einmal nur minimal wäre
könnte er den kurs mit einer gewissen
vorlaufzeit im laufe der zeit immer
weiter verschieben doch erst einmal
müsste das raumschiff überhaupt gebaut
werden die mission und die flugzeit
geplant werden und je mehr zeit vergeht
umso schwieriger gestaltet sich dieser
plan zehn jahre vor dem errechneten
einschlag von benny bräuchte mal schon
bis zu 53 hemmers um sein kurs zu ändern
oder aber man agiert doch mit einer
atombombe gegen ihn
wobei es hierbei auch wieder einige
riesen gibt risiken könnte in mehrere
teile aufgespalten werden die dann
weiterhin kurs auf die erde nehmen
ihr könnt euch alle ausmalen was bei
einem asteroideneinschlag auf der erde
passieren könnte hollywood filme dazu
gibt es ja genug fliegende trümmer
tsunami wellen und schlimme erdbeben
etwa könnten wirklich ein großteil des
lebens auf der erde auslöschen
doch viel mehr sorgen machen sich
forschungsteams um die kleineren objekte
denn von ihnen sind geschätzt nur ein
prozent bekannt ganz im gegensatz zu den
gigantischen gesteinsbrocken aus dem all
die nasa und die anderen
weltraumagenturen auf dem schirm haben
das hat beispielsweise auch der
überraschende einschlag des asteroiden
in der nähe des ural gebirges
chelyabinsk im jahr 2013 gezeigt er
hatte einen durchmesser von 20 metern
und wog etwa 16.000 tonnen
doch rund 1500 menschen wurden verletzt
und 700 gebäude wurden beschädigt fest
steht jedenfalls hätte man dies
vorausgesehen hätte man schlimmeres ganz
einfach verhindern können dass bloße
öffnen der gebäude fenster hätte den
großteil der schäden vermeiden können
und um genau das schon frühzeitig voraus
zu sagen nämlich wie viele hast du jeden
wann genau der erde nahe kommen könnten
müsste der komplette nachthimmel
regelmäßig abgescannt werden erst im
juni diesen jahres hat die nasa
ein strategiepapier zu asteroiden abwehr
vorgelegt demnach müssen dringend
möglichkeiten entwickelt werden mit
denen die flugbahnen der gesteinsbrocken
beeinflusst werden können auch hier
betont die nasa noch einmal dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit für einen schlimmen
einschlag gering ist doch die folgen
umso katastrophaler und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen
jedes jahr gibt es rund zwei asteroiden
einschläge von denen wir allerdings kaum
etwas mitbekommen weil sie meistens in
unbewohntem gebiet einschlagen bis 2020
sollen jetzt alle erdnahen asteroiden
die größer sind als 140 meter entdeckt
zuverlässig entdeckt werden können
experten und expertinnen plädieren immer
wieder für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystem auch in
europa macht man sich gedanken dazu die
esa plant im kommenden jahr ein neues
teleskop auf sie zielt aufzubauen um den
nachthimmel nach objekten abzusuchen ein
solches teleskop würde das innerhalb von
maximal vier nächten schaffen um den
himmel in einer nacht ab zu scannen
bräuchte es drei bis vier solcher
teleskop wenn ihr keine videos dazu und
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht
er die kaputte abo box er auf you tube
und verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr mehr von
mir noch vor allen andern vom neuesten
video ich schicke euch dann vorher eine
nachricht und zwar täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür da klicken aber nicht die
können auch die glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit
achtung darauf auch dann klicken die
erde in die knapp einem großen
asteroiden einschlag bis dann bleibt
dran